the stakes are high for all of the
candidates who will appear in the
theater right behind us tomorrow night
but they are especially high for Joe
Biden why the former vice president had
a substantial lead here but he's dropped
in recent polls notice notably among the
state's black voters who make up about
60% of the Democrats that vote here so
we visited with a number of black voters
over the weekend as well as campaign
organizers and veteran volunteers they
told us this campaign is as competitive
as ever cut your TVs off and stay
focused
Bernie Scott is a force in South
Carolina politics we got a lot of work
to do whether she's organizing
volunteers at her home and I hate
talking to you about the issues greeting
people door-to-door or adding emphasis
through a bullhorn on a Joe Biden
campaign bus her voice is a trusted one
in the Palmetto State when we arrived to
meet her last Friday we were greeted by
the group she founded more than 30 years
ago they are known as a reckoning crew
why did you call it the reckoning crew
because if you don't do what's right by
the people you have to reckon with us
the group of now mostly senior citizen
organizers initially endorsed senator
Kamala Harris after she suspended her
campaign The Reckoning crew made
headlines for backing Joe Biden what is
it about Joe Biden that you feel a
personal connection because our country
is so far back now till Joe Biden worked
eight years with Barack Obama we need
somebody who can hit the ground running
the former vice president had a
formidable lead in South Carolina but
according to a new CBS News battleground
tracker poll his support among the
state's black voters fell from 54% in
November to 35% are you concerned about
what's going to happen to your candidate
of choice in South Carolina no not
really because all we can do as a
wreckin cru is take the message to the
people and if a train is coming down the
track
and I tell you to get off the track and
you don't move I could feel good knowing
I told you joe biden's dropped in the
polls offers his Democratic rivals
greater expectations for the next
primary but the three of you were here
to say we have a different story we went
to the University of South Carolina in
Columbia to meet with young organizers
pulling for Elizabeth Warren Bernie
Sanders and Pete Budaj edge so I'm very
fascinated because your full name is
what Walter a Clyburn dream Clyburn ding
ding ding ding ding we all know the
clobber name yes ma'am so your
grandfather congressman Clyburn has been
on record as saying that mayor Pete
sexual orientation will be a problem for
some voters he said he's not necessarily
talking about himself he said but many
voters in South Carolina black voters in
particular is know that that would be a
problem he was referring to to his
generation in particular he understands
that our nation is progressing and he
also understands how much that community
has a positive effect on not only
American Society but eventually American
politics I want to say this about you
Alex I so admire you because you're 16
and you can't even vote in this election
yet at 16 I was just hoping please
somebody ask me to the prom
what is it about politics that
fascinates you as I grew up I realized
that politics is gonna affect me and
everybody else and so when I was
witnessing the 2016 election that's when
I really found out that it matters who
you vote for you settled on Bernie
Sanders why he's a candidate who has
fought for the civil rights movement as
far as policies like Medicare for all
getting money out of politics and ending
to overseas Wars because that's what I
wouldn't run on if I couldn't run do you
think the stakes are higher this time
sanim I think they are because you know
the last four years so many people have
been afraid of where this country is
headed and I think you know Elizabeth
Warren says herself this is the fight of
our lives Walter we talked before about
the how people view voters of color that
it's a monolithic group and when you
hear that what do you think that is very
untrue we all have different different
viewpoints and in this election in
particular we have a lot
of candidates who have a lot to offer in
the state capitol we talked with voters
at a Family Fun Run I narrowed it down
I'm down to two who seemed to agree the
race for the Democratic nomination in
South Carolina remains wide open we
still have more time I still have more
time to change my mind I'm still
researching in so we'll see so will the
debates matter to you they do they
matter a lot I do yes you can't retract
what you've said in front of millions of
Watchers how are you appealing to the
african-american voters yeah and so
that's never part of the voter the
voters is you know that and this
community here in this community looks
like 60% that's important I need to know
she needs to know Walter who you saw in
that piece is trying to convince his
grandfather Congressman Jim Clyburn to
back mayor Pete Budaj who young Walter
is supporting but the congressman told
us he plans to announce his endorsement
on Wednesday after the debate and ahead
of the primary although it's being
widely reported today that he is
expected to endorse Vice President Joe
Biden we shall see and 16 year old Alex
told us he's interested in running for
office one day he's 16 he said he can
run for Congress when he's 25 and
something tells me you have not heard
the last of Alex says he was ready to go
now gale the camera really is yes he is
ready to go now now get those women The
Reckoning crew what do they think of
that 19 percent drop in support for Joe
Biden in the state among black voters
you know I think it's what Bernie said
look all you can do is give them the
message and let them decide for
themselves they are concerned but they
said they're not worried they actually
but they are concerned and I have to say
they're a little worried but they think
at the end of the day Joe Biden will
pull it out in South Carolina but even a
close close lead for him close victory
for him is not considered a good side
yeah yeah I love that name reckoning
crew though that's just a great I do too
they think the train is coming
all right Gail thank you very much we'll
check in with you later you guys